thank you welcome to this mid-suffolk
overview of scrutiny committee meeting
I'm councilman Keith wellum and I'm
chairing the meeting today
I'll first remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
that your mobile phones are on silent or
Switched Off and the volume on your
laptops and other devices are turned
down to zero
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consult consented to
being filmed by entering this meeting as
a speaker you are also consenting to
being recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film or photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
so in attendance at the present time we
have the members of the committee we
have I believe I may miss somebody out I
try not to minister Evans who is the
director for corporate resources
Emily ATAC at the back there director
for assets and Investments
Holly Brett
corporate manager for the council's
companies
and we've got other people here as well
so could could you could you introduce
your colleagues please Melissa
I can't do yet so my left I've got uh
Sharon Bayless who's the servant I
forgot your title service improvement
advisor and operations but she's been
helping us out on the budget and then to
my right I've got Rebecca Hewitt who's
the corporate manager for finance and
commission procurement
thank you and we also have
councilor John wise head who is the
cabinet member for finance we have Susie
Morley who is the leader of mid-suffle
council and we have Andrew Mellon who is
the lead signatory for the call-in and
we're we're all being supported by by
various governance support officers
so can I move to the agenda please
and agenda item one is apologies for
absence and substitutions please
received
chair thank you uh are there any
Declarations of pecuniary or other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
there are none
have there been any petitions in
accordance with the council's petitions
scheme
thank you
questions by the public
we have a question from Victoria cup
cutmore of endurance Estates
of one Station Road Foxton Cambridge and
she asks
given there is a Justified need for
housing in Ellsworth as set out in
cabinet report MCA 2227
and a desire for a new Primary School in
elmsworld
our members are aware that the land to
the east of Eastern way elmsworld is
available to provide an Exemplar Housing
Development and land for a future
primary school as an alternative to or
in addition to the land at Church Road
and we have an answer to
Victoria cupmore's question from the
director of planning
which I will read out
the council is aware of land held by
endurance Estates in Elmo's World which
was promoted to the council through the
Baba and mid-suffolk Joint local plan
process
there is a locally expressed desire for
a new Primary School
but it should be noted that this is not
a feature of Suffolk County council's
Education and learning infrastructure
plan
or this council's joint infrastructure
delivery plan
the council will be developing its part
2 joint local plan in accordance with
the timetable published in its local
development scheme
which will include a call for sites
Elms were also developing their own
neighborhood plan which would provide a
further mechanism for you to promote
your land for development
and as the quest the question that is
not present there will not be a
Forest gym but she has heard and will
receive a written response to her
question thank you
[Applause]
are there any questions by counselors
please
none received here
thank you now we move on to item six
which is the general fund and housing
revenue account for
2023-24 review of savings proposals and
updated
position
um can I remind members that we are
considering at this item both the
general fund and the housing revenue
account
think that labor members or at least one
of them got a bit confused when they
thought that they were two separate
items
this is just to make it absolutely clear
there is one item and I'd like to invite
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce the report to the committee
thank you chairman and good afternoon
members at the November ons committee
meeting you reviewed the set of
assumptions behind our draft budgets for
23.24 and both iron officers appreciated
the observations and recommendations
arising from your debate on the subject
and which have been carefully considered
over the intervening period as further
iterations of the draft budget have been
developed
today this new report provides LNS the
opportunity to consider the latest draft
budgets for the general fund and the HRA
before they go to cabinet on the 6th of
February and then to full Council on the
23rd of February
subscribe to our last meeting we now
have the benefit of the quarter two
monitoring report for the current year
central government has announced his
provisional settlement for 23.24
and government has determined the
maximum increase permissible for Council
house rents in 2324
paragraph 3.2 sets out the headlines of
the Q2 monitoring position
key headlines from the government
settlement are set out in paragraphs
paragraph 4.10
and information arises from the
government's decision on 23 24 maximum
rent increases is set out in paragraphs
5.10 to 5.12
we are happy to answer any questions you
have arising from those three
developments
now starting with a general fund we have
set out a summary table table one in the
report
showing how the financial pressures
savings and additional income Reserve
movements and funding changes have each
impacted positively or negatively on the
2324 position
there are some significant numbers here
so we break them out into components of
the pressures and Savings in tables two
and tables three
tables such as these can only include a
very brief description for each of those
components but hopefully many if not all
will be self-explanatory but again we'd
be happy to explain any of them in more
detail in committee members request
further clarification
our Reserve position in mid-suffolk
remains strong and as explained in
paragraph 418 we've recently received
some significant Capital receipts from
Gateway 14. to the extent that we no
longer need to set aside the large
commercial development risk management
Reserve
every cabinet meeting I'll be
recommending that the reserve is
repurposed along with the growth and
efficiency fund into a new combined
strategic transformation and
infrastructure fund
we have in the pipeline some ambitious
projects to finance such as a shelf
project and a skills and Innovation
Center on Gateway 14.
step members on the committee will
conclude that the report presented today
demonstrates that the general fund for
2324 is in a good position
there is a forecasted surplus of over 3
million for 23 24 general fund despite
all these cost pressures and in these
circumstances I feel it would be
perverse to recommend anything other
than the council tax freeze for our
medicine folks share of the overall 2324
precept
now turning to the HRA it is clear that
we do face a more challenging situation
in this ring fenced account
we anticipate a deficit outturn in 23 20
2223 and we are presenting a deficit
budget of 2324
we can tolerate that in the short term
by funding the deficits from reserves
but clearly that can't be sustainable in
the medium to long term
given all the destruction from covid the
unprecedented inflation in material
repairs and build costs and the
challenges raised by our Net Zero
commitments the housing team will as
much of urgency be producing a revised
30-year business plan for the HRA during
2324
so I regard this HRA budget for the next
year as a realist realistic assessment
of the next 12 months ahead whilst a
business plan to tackle the many
challenges faced by the HRA is developed
during that period thank you Chad
thank you we now have a Time
councilor Morley
thank you chair as
this item I'm substitute
your housing portfolio and if you're
willing I'd like to read out a statement
on her behalf yeah sorry I wasn't aware
that you were doing that yes please
carry on I'm multitasking
thank you chair the HRA like the general
fund is under increasing pressure
partially due to Rising costs for
materials pay Awards and an aging
housing stock
the government has recommended an
increase in rents of seven percent and
the council has recommended that this be
put forward as the increase for next
year
even with this increase there is a
deficit of 409 000 pounds
furthermore the previous rent reductions
have increased the risk to the HRA
this with increasing regulation and an
urgent need for sustainability to our
stock means the future will be
challenging
officers are working to increase income
particularly around maximizing garage
rentals an area currently
underperforming and driving down rent
areas by providing additional support to
tenants and maximizing the impact of our
rent sense software
officers are currently working with a
provider to overhaul the business plan
this will allow members to take a
30-year view of income and proposed
expenditure and members can expect this
at the next round of budget setting
thank you chair
thank you
we'll move on to questions now if there
are questions which you would like a
more detailed housing response to
I understand that the director housing
is online and probably watching and will
wave a hand if she has an answer for us
to any of our questions
so it's questions only questions of
cabinet members and officers so who
would like to start
counteracting young thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um
so the
councilor Whitehead has
given us a really good summary of where
we are with the general fund
my question is really with regard to the
table number four which relates to
savings and increases in incomes which
in total represent probably if just over
50 percent uh mitigation against the
pressures
uh my concern is as to whether actually
um how realistic these savings and
increases are I I note the fact that 10
of them are earmarked as other and what
would happen if they didn't realize
thank you Council Whitehead
thank you um well obviously a lot of
time left has been put into both the you
know um identifying the pressures and
looking for mitigating savings or
increase in income
they are evolving I I think there may be
some concerns about one or two headings
for example they would be profiling the
Leisure contract just because of
pressures that there are coming through
at the moment but as a general rule I
think they're reasonably sound and being
bear in mind that we're still reporting
a surplus of three million for next year
that's a great deal of Headroom against
potential savings there of 2.2 million
is there a follow-up
right
uh anyone else
can be a very quick meeting
councilor castle and then Council scarf
thank you
thank you very much and Mr chairman
um I'd just like a little bit more
information on two in table three to the
general fund pressures
um the first one being the removing of
the savings contingency
and the second one um
the increase in the training budget and
the the thoughts behind
um those as um as pressures
please
in terms of the first question the 90
000 removal of savings continues
Finance colleagues who live and
breathing day to day so it sounds for
that one and if you any comments you
want to make on the training budget as
well if you don't mind
thank you councilor Whitehead thank you
for the question
um yeah so the savings contingency was a
historical uh budget line we had in
um that was set aside for aspirations
around savings targets so what we've
done is stripped that out and replaced
it with more robust uh savings proposals
if you like so I I was never a fan of
kind of a savings contingency for me I
like you know a detailed plan to sit
behind that so that's just removing that
element of contingency if you like that
I wasn't particularly comfortable with
because there was no no plans behind it
if you like
um and the second question around the
training and budget some of that is a
carry forward and some of its additional
budget and that says the response to a
lot of work the HR and OD team have been
doing with officers around training
needs there's a lot of quality and
diversity training we want to undertake
next year there's also a large-scale
leadership program we want to introduce
um supporting our Apprentice as well we
want to really invest in that side of
things as well and I think our learning
platform because we want to invest in
that as well I think that's going to
cost us a little bit more next year as
well so there's some detailed learning
Development coming through from that
additional budget
thank you
um councilor scarf
yep we're back again okay
um a couple of questions really uh on
page 11
um you talk about the combination of the
development risk management reserve and
the growth efficiency Reserve being
Amalgamated by cabinet in
um
one question on that is my understanding
of the members locality budgets are
funded currently from the growth and
efficiency fund does this new strategic
infrastructure fund allow
that ability to fund ongoing
locality budgets
that's question one
and then on page 14 when we're talking
about 5.11
he said it's been assumed that there'll
be no properties purchased by the tenant
through the right to buy mechanism for
23
4
and the number of voyages based on the
2022 to 23 rate of seven percent
um
why are there why will there be no
why is the Assumption basically that
they're going to be no right to buys
this year is that because of the
economic conditions is that based on uh
previous factors because I might be
wrong but I think
year that was 12. so why would there be
none this year just like some
explanation on that one
um and and finally just a
comment I'm really pleased that you've
recommendations about
the Gap I know it's a small sum but I'm
very pleased to see it in the table
thank you
thank you oh well my understanding is
that the um they have the same amount in
for this coming year for their
localities
budget at budgets sorry look out his
grants funding and certainly no change
in the status of um reserves which
should affect that going forward I think
we all value very much the opportunity
to help
our communities through the local
government sorry the local grant
localities grant scheme and um in terms
of um you've got your questions on the
HRA
um
I certainly have a lot of sympathy with
what you're asking in terms of the the
fact that there are we're assuming no
right to buy the numbers do vary year to
year so it's very much almost like
of the lottery to decide what figure to
use
um you know a figure of zero has been
chosen
um which is
um
probably not an overproven figure but
within the whole scheme of things of
three thousand houses it'll only be a
trivial amount in terms of lost rent and
of course any right to buy can happen
anytime during the year as well so it
wouldn't be a four years rental loss but
rather than just pluck a figure out the
air
um particularly in the presence
situation and the cost of living crisis
we've just gone for zero
um you question about the seven percent
voice well I said let me know that's
based on on last
so we're just assuming that going
forward at the moment let's say this
obviously a draft budget and you know I
know your comments and uh appreciate the
uh the thoughts from where we're next in
terms of about
Barry's rent so we are pleased to
incorporate that keep
do you have a follow-up question at all
was it present councilor Acme um please
thank you chairman um I have a follow-up
to counselor's class question in fact
um and there are two of them one is with
regard to the locality budget would the
a portfolio holder and the offices look
at possibly increasing the locality
budgets for the next financial year
there are a lot of pressures within our
communities to help them with lots of
different projects and anyone involved
in it would have known that the monies
that we had this year just didn't go far
enough so that's my first point to the
question the second is I'm trying to
understand why the lack of properties
purchased through the right to buy
mechanism would would generate an
additional 1.3 million of income that
could be explained
okay thank you
um well it's in terms of the characters
budget at the moment let's say we've got
the same amount going forward to this
current year I can certainly understand
in uh in terms of 10 inflation there
might be a valid reason to increase the
add-ons and if only less wanted to put
that forward as a recommendation for us
to think about it's our cabinet meeting
then you know they're not obviously R Us
can can do that
um in terms of your question about the
1.3 million and are you looking at table
nine in the 1.297 is that what
I'm sorry counselor I'm looking at uh
item 5.11
yeah so I I think it's it's a certain
lack of clarity I think in the wording
there because they the one two nine
three additional income includes all the
extra rental income from putting the
rents up by seven percent
plus the right to buy assumptions plus
the voice assumptions it's almost I
think 5.10 or 5.11 perhaps could have
been run into just one one paragraph
because I'll just clarify that yes but
yeah so I said a big driver there is the
well one two nine one point two nine and
seven million is generated from the rent
increase of seven percent and that's
reduced a little bit by the the voice
and right to buy assumptions thank you
any further questions for anybody
uh can I can I ask a question about the
HRA account and I failed to
um introduce the director of operations
who is with us
and this may be a question for him so
only fair to introduce him
um my my question is around the
availability and and cost of materials
and trades people and predicting
inflation and so on
um I I've had
a number of officers who've said to me
it's very difficult to get Rufus or it's
very difficult to get
various different trades and in any case
the materials are still going up so
um
how
how confident are you or how confident
is the director of housing that that
we've got the right sort of amount of
money in the sums there in the table
um and what happens if we can't get the
materials and the trades people does
that mean that
the work is delayed yet again that's
been delayed through covered shortage of
material shortage of Chase people are
are we are we out of the woods as far as
those sorts of things are concerned
please
yeah
shall I come in yes please do
good good afternoon members so in terms
of being out of the woods we we are in
the situation where we have got a
reducing
um number of outstanding repairs
um what we've done to try and mitigate
some of the challenges is bring on uh
bring on a number of contractors
on a short-term basis and what we're
working through at the moment is our
transformation as you'll be aware and
this does include looking at um a
framework of contractors in addition to
our own trades team so what that will
enable us to do is to deal with the
urban this of the ebb and flow of works
as it comes through and it is good
practice to always have a number a
number of options
um so that's what we'll be doing going
forward
um and as I've just alluded to in the in
the short term we have got some
short-term contracts in place
in terms of whether we've got the
correct budget there we've done a
substantial amount of work on budgets
looking at what we think the cost will
be over the next few years we've also
been looking at our Capital costs in
terms of component Replacements it's
bathroom
really wildlife
Etc
so we think we're there
and we are currently also working with
um a provider who's got expertise in
business planning for for the HRA and we
are planning an overhaul of our business
plan and this will hopefully give
members more Assurance in the future
around what our
um income will be and what our expected
costs will be
I'm not sure if there's any follow-up
questions after that uh thank you not a
follow-up question but is a completely
different question
um and that is I think it is for you
Deborah and it's around it's around
um void void times void percentages and
so on
um overview security did quite a lot of
work on looking at voids two or three
years ago
um but I think that voids void times
have crept up again
um I think in mid-suffolk more than in
baber or that when I last looked at the
figures that was the case I don't think
there's any particular reason for that
um but
um are you are you optimistic I'm sure
you're optimistic
um can we can we expect that the boy
times will come down uh and uh is the
reason that they've gone up their
availability or lack of availability of
Trades people and materials
so there I am optimistic I'm always
optimistic and I always have a plan so I
have been working
um on voids and there's a number of
um things we've already put in place
firstly we've got a subcontractor who
can help us
um with the
um you know the backlog of boys because
we have got a backlog now and we can't
expect to be
um completing all those voids with the
the team we've got internally so our new
contractor we're hoping will start at
the beginning of February so that is the
first
um mitigation number two what we've been
doing is we've been replacing kitchens
and bathrooms in voids
um that's not cost effective
um also holds up the void doesn't
contend a choice
um and so so what we've done around that
is we've we're developing our component
replacement plan so these are our
Capital plans kitchens and bathrooms
um
um as of a couple of weeks ago I gave
the teams the introduction that now all
kitchens and bathrooms unless absolutely
necessary have to be put in the plan
that will bring down the cost as well
because it's a lot more expensive to do
a kitchen or a bathroom in a void than
it than it is to do in a a planned way
um so so so that's mitigation number two
mitigation number three in in the short
term what we do have is we we have a you
know I'll be really honest we've got a
lot of voids a lot of boys that need
work doing so so my priority and the
priority of the team is to get people
housed as soon as possible so we've
changed the approach to voids and the
the work in the void is now
um housing lead so um twice a week the
housing team are up in a meeting with
the boys team and they're saying right
these are the properties we've got
allocated and these are the properties
we want you to
concentrate on
um so so do the works first so so what
that means is we House people quicker
and they're not waiting so those are
three steps we've taken in the short
term
um to try and you know mitigate what
what what is you know quite a
significant significant issue there will
of course be more
systemic changes coming through with the
transformation plan but of course we
know it's really important that
um just we can't just sort of rest on
The Laurels and wait for a
transformation
um to start we have to
um you know we we have we have to you
know do what we can now
um and the the the increase in the voids
um in in terms of rent loss is linked to
the um increase in
um
uh sorry increasing in in rents so the
cost of the rents
yeah I think I understand you're saying
if we if we shorten the employee time we
increase the income
yes absolutely absolutely thank you
has anybody got any further questions
for Deborah
in case she Fades off the screen
well thank you very much
um for your input
um
any any further questions from anyone
cancer Young
thank you Mr chairman
um looking at table two on page seven in
the general fund section
um I noticed that I'm curious as to why
our interests payable is going to shoot
up by almost a factor of four
um you know by 800 000 pounds given that
you know the significant Capital
receipts that we've received
um I seems are rather odd that interests
payable should be shooting up by that
much if at all
um
I'm thinking it's really because we're
coming off such a low base in terms of
interest rates with base rates going up
from half percent to four and a half or
whatever but I'll just ask Melissa to
either say yes to that or counteract me
thanks for the question
so a lot
a lot currently have have still got a
term to mature so they are maturing part
way three 23 24 so we can't you know
clear those any earlier than the
maturity would be end up paying the
interest that we would do to pay on them
so we need to let those run their course
so there isn't an element of increased
charges for next year until we can
actually not renew those loans if that
makes sense
no so when we took the loans out some of
them had a term to run say for example
until July this year so we need to build
in the interest The increased interest
that we would be paying on that going
forward
so are you saying that they were not at
fixed interest rates some of them we've
taken out later this year so that
they're not they're not 0.4 percent
they're at the higher rate so we have
been having to take some loans out
before we got the capital receipt back
from Gateway 14 so they have got a term
to mature at a higher rate
still seems a hell of a lot of money
from from where we were I I think you
know
some explanation of that increase in
more detail would be desirable just just
checking with my colleague to the right
here there's also an element of new
borrowing in there because there are
some schemes coming forward that we will
do some borrowing so whilst it will put
us on a if you like a level field
without that no borrowing the investment
we're going to be doing in our Capital
program will mean that we will need to
take out some more boring going forward
so that will come up a cost
so I'm sorry why we're needing to borrow
so much money if we've got plenty of
surpluses
let's say it's it's not putting us in
the Surplus position it's putting us in
a break-even position if you like in our
bank balance so we're not we won't be
necessarily sitting with a huge Surplus
because we've got about 40 million
pounds worth of short-term borrowing so
it's not going to put us in a in a huge
Surplus position and with the investment
that we're proposing in the capital
program for a lot of the big schemes
coming forward will then be needing to
to borrow on top of that
do I have any further questions from
members
can we move on to debate
is there anyone who wants to debate any
aspect I think cancer equity on your
work you had a suggestion for adding to
the recommendation
I mean my only point would be that we
look at increasing the locality budget
for the next financial year German
thank you is there anything that anyone
else would like as a a supplementary
recommendation
to go to cabinet
so we are asked to
note
the draft recommend the draft Revenue
budget set out in the report for 23 24
general fund and housing revenue account
and
we uh we ask
uh cabinet to consider in an increase
in the locality award allocation to each
member
Council scarf
need a second over that particular
reference have I uh well thank you are
you happy with what I have
quality back to you councilor young as
your proposal
thank you so we have a proposal we have
a second
um and do you want to type that in or
shall I just read it out
[Music]
so it will now
get the
electronic phones
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chairs that is six votes for
recommendations so it's unanimous
and members are
um the monitoring officer will be with
us at 2 30 for the call-in item are you
happy if we if we uh wait till 2 30 but
in the meantime
um we can look at items seven and eight
which are the forthcoming decisions list
uh has anybody got any comments on
forthcoming decisions list
no thank you the forthcoming decisions
list is for noting
and our overview and scrutiny work plan
does anyone have any comments
the uh baber overview excuse me meeting
this morning I suggested I
added them to their work plan
around
sort of something around a business plan
for
public realm looking at whether or not
um
Baba District had a better service a
more cost effective Service as a result
of the insourcing of their
Mowing and cutting their public realm
contract they it had been contracted out
prior to about 12 months ago they've now
had 12 months of it being in-house
um before before that happened
we as a committee
the mid-suffer had concerns around a
potential loss of service or increased
cost
if the whole service were brought in
um and uh baber said they'd like to have
a look at all of that so rather than
they have a look at it from the baber
point of view would you be happy if we
added that to the Joint overview and
screw to the work plan rather than
just to the favor of your scrutiny work
plan
so if you are I'm seeing nodes so
um we will we will do that
um and when you'll see the revised work
planned
um in the next at the next meeting
so we'll we'll have a break now for
around around 10 minutes
um and if we can all be back here in
about 10 minutes time
we should then be
item nine which is the calling of
mid-suffolk cabinet decision on 7th of
December 2022
before we look at the calling itself
we're asked to consider and approve the
call-in protocol members you've all had
an opportunity to read through the
protocol that we're asked to adopt for
this item
we need to adopt this protocol before we
consider the details of the call in
could I have a proposal please councilor
Caston
and could I have a second to please
counselor
I'll now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members at voters now in
progress
thank you chair that is six votes for
search unanimous
right this this is this is how we're
going to go through this item
I will read out the call-in notice
then the next steps will be as follows
the lead signatory Council of melon will
explain the reason for the call in and
why the committee should scrutinize the
decision taken by cabinet
he has a maximum of 10 minutes
councilman Morley will have 10 minutes
to present the reasons why the decision
was taken by cabinet
committee members will then ask
questions of councilman Mellon and
councilor Morley
questions Must Fall within the scope of
the call in
committee members May then ask questions
of officers and or other members if
there are any in attendance members of
cabinet
committee members May then ask further
questions of councilman and or councilor
Morley
councilor Morley will then provide a
summary of her case and she has five
minutes
councilman will then provide a summary
of his case and he has five minutes
members of cabinet and the lead
signatory will then leave the meeting
members of the committee will then
debate the issue members will need to
decide whether to refer the matter back
to cabinet
at or to uphold the cabinet decision in
which case it will be implemented
immediately either way reasons for the
committee's decision are required
and it is not appropriate for this uh
this matter to be referred to council
so we have two choices we either refer
it back to cabinet
or we
um we uphold the decision
so are we all content we we've approved
the protocol but that's just an
explanation
right
this is a calling notice
a call in of the cabinet decision MCA
MCA 20
to 27 elsewhere Exemplar housing scheme
made on 7th of November 2022.
we the undersigned while supporting the
intention to bring forward Exemplar
housing in the district
wish to call this Covenant decision in
for examination by the scrutiny
committee for the following reasons
the cabinet was not presented with all
the information required in order to
make an informed and Sound Decision
whilst this area of land is owned by the
HRA and the cabinet report describes it
as suitable for housing
it is also an important and well used
open space within Ellsworth Village
it is not clear that in the current
planning policy context and in the light
of the very recent development control
decision committee decision on
application DC
2203423 also announcement that a
planning application for housing on this
site would be successful in gaining
permission
the risk might make the risk Matrix grid
on page 146 of the cabinet papers
describe the likelihood of the site not
gaining permission as two and the impact
is three
and recommends in mitigation that
thorough engagement with all
stakeholders throughout the design and
process and planning process
however no information was presented as
to whether any engagement had taken
place with development control to
support this act this assessment of the
risk
no consequential test or supporting
information was presented to Cabinet to
validate the selection of this site
above any other site or site in the
district for example our housing
other than that this is a large site
within the ownership of the HRA
other possibilities that had not been
considered include
a district-wide call for sites to
deliver an Exemplar scheme which may
well have brought forward more
sustainable alternative sites in
community or private ownership or a land
swap Within ellsworld which could
provide an alternative location for the
Exemplar housing scheme whilst keeping
this site available for future education
provision in elmsworth which is the
communities clearly stated intention
so we now go on to
the lead signatory to present the reason
for the call in and why the committee
should scrutinize the decision
councilman you have 10 minutes
here representing the other signatories
the calling who were councilors Mount
saw geek Fields otton Matheson and
Stringer
unfortunately none of the rest could be
present this afternoon or they may they
may be watching it online
I'm grateful for the committee's time
this afternoon to examine this call in
I'd like to start with some opening
remarks
about the scheme before going on to look
in detail at the reasons for the call-in
request I should probably also State for
the record although I called this
decision in as a district counselor I
also represent elmswell and the
surrounding villages on the County
Council
the aspiration to deliver low-carbon
homes is a good one which we support
in fact we wish that all new homes
delivered in the district would be built
in this way it would go a long way
towards meeting the district and the
County's stated goal of reaching Net
Zero carbon emissions by 2030.
it would also provide homes which are
cheap to run a very important
consideration when the cost of living
has risen so much in the past year
we are also in complete and wholehearted
agreement with the key design goals
which were set out in point 11.3 of the
cabinet reports
these being people in nature first
improving green infrastructure using
orientation for passive and active solar
gain
respecting neighboring properties and
local Heritage and a fabric first and
future proof approach these all would
add up to provide a place which would be
pleasant to live in where walking and
cycling are supported and encouraged
and where well-built homes are embedded
in the living landscape
again these are principles that all
developers should be following
but whilst supporting the broad
intentions of this of this end
commending the officer's work on it we
do have some concerns about the decision
hence the call-in request
and there are two main aspects of this
decision which we believe were not
addressed either by the cabinet report
nor the subsequent debate a cabinet 7th
of November last year
the first point is around planning
whilst the piece of land in question is
owned by the council's HRA it does not
have even outlying consent for house
building and whilst the the area is
allocated in the emerging joint local
plan as potential development land its
allocation
la064 for around 60 homes as we all know
the jlp is still under examination and
adoption even if part one is still some
way off in the future
so the land's current status is is a
piece of well-used open immunity land
towards the edge of a village which has
seen an enormous amount of development
in the last few years
so the key point is this we have no
indication that in the current policy
context this site would gain permission
for development
surely a key consideration when deciding
whether to move forward with the scheme
and just to illustrate this there was a
decision taken by development control
committee a
on another application you know as well
just two days after the cabinet meeting
and this was for one dwelling to be
built off Crown Mill dc22 stroke zero
three four two three and that was
refused
and the primary reason being I quote
from the refusal notification
bite is subject
it's proposed there's an existing area
of open space and should only be built
on if the local Authority is satisfied
that the requirements of paragraph 99 of
the mppf have been met
the open space is an intrinsically
important emergency space for local
residents and the community
contributing to their well-being it's
lost demonstrably adversely affects the
character and parents of the settlement
and open space
provide important facilities or
amenities for the local community
so if that applies to the footprint for
wonder One dwelling surely it would
apply even more to the land under
consideration for the 50 home
development
however in the committee report we are
given no indication of this
the risk Matrix at 8.1 which is on page
six of the cabinet report does
acknowledge that the scheme may not
achieve planning consent and suggests in
mitigation thorough engagement with all
stakeholders
throughout the design and planning
process however to date no informal
discussions with planning officers
appear to have taken place nor yet for
more pre-planning advice or if it has
taken a place it would
reported to cabinet
the second main point of concern
regarding this decision is the
justification of this site for this
scheme
this this is the best place
all we are told is that the land is in
the ownership of HRA and is therefore
suitable for housing
I think what would have been helpful
would have been a list of all the HRA
owned sites above a certain size across
the district with some kind of Rough and
Ready ranking of their suitability for
development for this type of scheme
this site has been chosen but the
cabinet was not given information as to
whether any sequential tests have been
applied to the selection
it could also be the case that there is
other land available in the district for
a scheme such as this land currently
owned by parishes communities or even
privately and a district-wide call for
sites May well have brought forward
another site or sites which are suitable
or possibly more suitable or less
contentious than this site
for example land already in a community
Land Trust
the cabinet report states that there is
Need for affordable homes in Ellsworth
but this is not Quantified and of course
Elm saw has seen a large number of new
homes built in recent years including
some developments still under
construction
many of which are delivering their
proportion of affordable homes
the parish council itself has plans
deliver an affordable housing scheme on
land behind the elmswell tavern
so it's not clear how far the proposed
Exemplar scheme meets the need for
affordable homes in Elms well
whether that need is already being met
from existing developments or whether
the proposed Exemplar scheme would
undermine
Parish council's own plans
in conclusion Mr chairman for the
reasons I've outlined above I believe
that the cabinet decision should be
Revisited
the cabinet report may or may not be
sound but it was lacking I believe in
some respects incomplete and more
information is is required if the
cabinet is to make a sound and informed
decision
thank you councilman and we move
straight on to
uh councilor Morley to present the
reasons why the decision was taken thank
you
thank you chair
in November a report was brought to
Cabinet to secure funding for the
development of a site owned by the
council in elmswell as an Exemplar
sustainable housing scheme
this would be subject to the usual
development gateways being achieved such
as Community engagement and seeking to
achieve planning consent
the cabinet supported the
recommendations set out in the report we
are Keen to deliver new low-carbon
affordable and Market housing providing
high quality homes with lower running
costs
which is even more important during the
current cost of living challenges
elmswell is a sustainable Village
benefiting from good public transport
links and local facilities and this site
is already within the ownership of the
council making it a viable option for an
Exemplar low-carbon scheme
by approving the budget and the
appointment of our own development
company mid-suffolk growth Limited at
this early stage in the project the
cabinet or enabling the project to
progress
through development gateways and did so
in the knowledge that if those gateways
such as planning and wider Community
engagement were not successful the
development would not proceed but
equally if the development gateways were
achieved that necessary budgets would be
in place to progress the development
since the cabinet meeting in November
and the subsequent calling of that
decision
first public engagement event has been
held with a number of residents
attending to share their views and a
petition against the proposed
development has also been received and
noted by cabinet
alongside this formal pre-application
advice has been received from the
planning Authority
the cabinet are Keen to deliver housing
that works well with existing
communities whilst delivering the
council's housing aspirations to provide
high quality housing for all
we value the contributions made by our
residents and in light of the
consultation feedback
and recent response from the planning
Authority we feel it is right to return
this item to cabinet for further
discussion
for further discussion on the options
available at this time and as such do
not contest this calling
thank you Jim
thank you very much
um I think I need a bit of guidance on
where we go from here do we
do we we still
um
monetary officer do we do we still go
through the whole process even though
the calling isn't contested
unfortunately yes once you've gone
through the process then you make your
decision based on what you've what
you've heard fine thank you very much
so committee members
would you like to ask questions of the
lead signatory and the cabinet member
questions to elicit further information
our councilor scarf
I've got one for councilor Morley
um
we now know that
the first round of Engagement has been
held and we know that we've got formal
pre-app advice from the planning
officers my question is
why it wasn't the consideration of this
advice
before cabinet actually looked at this
site because I think it would have given
you a an idea of whether
the planning officers were likely to
recommend or
not uh the planning application
when it surfaced
absolutely if it's all right I'll refer
to my director
thank you councilor for that question so
the purpose of this report was to secure
budget so that we could progress this
scheme it was a very early stage and
still is very early stages to see
whether this scheme is is viable and can
move forward through those development
gateways and so we had
um
taken some informal and planning advice
um over a number of years in relation to
this site and also reviewed the um
and the consultation that needed to be
undertaken needed a certain amount of
um drawings and information to share
with the local population in order for
that to be really beneficial but we
needed to secure the budget in order to
take it any further so there's an
element of you know it's a little bit
chicken and egg in terms of what comes
first obviously you don't spend that
budget until you successfully
progressed through the development
gateways
thank you any further questions
share this it's a question for councilor
Mellon um in the call-in
[Music]
um
it's muted that
the there is opposition to using this
land for example of housing but it might
be actually more suitable to build the
school and they just wanted the
rationale for that would be
councilman yeah um
so the
he's been sort of strongly expressed to
me by
um elmsworld Parish Council and
by various residents that this site
should be retained as use and used for a
school now
we did have a meeting with um
County Schools planning officer
a couple of weeks ago
um
where it was basically we were basically
told there was no immediate need for a
new school in elsewhere
um if there was Surplus pupils that's
probably the wrong phrase
pupils above and beyond what could be
accommodated at the existing School in
Ellsworth they would be educated over
the A14 in Wool pit
this is strongly
pose by
people in elmsworth as you could
probably understand
so whilst there's no immediate need for
a school a new school in elmswell
there's certainly a feeling in the
community that uh
attained whether you know when a school
may be needed in 15 20 years time
now clearly that
um the schools in the HRA the side of
the lands in the HRA it has to be used
for housing unless you know it can
persuade the Secretary of State
otherwise
there is potential for some creative
thinking I think here if um there's a
potential for a land swap within Elms
well
with land that the parish council owns
um just so that this site is retained
for future education
um
it is certainly something that's held
very strongly by the community
um I think it doesn't bear
perhaps a full examination because
because the numbers of pupils has over
dropped
recently expanded Ellsworth School to
some extent
I hope that answers the question
any further questions
right
um I think we've already had the
opportunity to ask questions of officers
are there any do you wish to in to ask
any any further questions of any offices
um
would in that case we move on
and I invite
the over councilor Morley
to provide a summary of the of the case
you may not need five minutes
housing that works well with existing
communities whilst delivering the
council's housing aspirations to provide
high quality housing for all
we value the contributions made by our
residents and in light of the
consultation feedback and recent
response from the planning Authority we
feel it is right to return this item to
cabinet for further discussion on the
options available at this time and as
such do not contest his calling
thank you and councilor Mellon
thank you chair
proposal is
described as an exempt class scheme I
did look up the word Exemplar in the
dictionary
and it's described as a typical example
or appropriate model and I think what is
meant in this context is is that a
development on this site if successful
would serve as a template or pattern for
the sort of development that would take
place subsequently in other locations
I.E we would learn from this development
I would just point out that else one has
already had an Exemplar low-carbon
housing scheme uh 26 Homes at clay
fields which were completed in 2008 and
even won a number of awards so it's not
clear what lessons from that previous
scheme are feeding into this current
proposal and the question is are we
doing the same thing again without
really learning from what happened a few
years ago
after the cabinet meeting on the 7th of
November an article appeared in the East
anglian I've got a copy of it here which
is slightly unfortunately
gave the headline plan for 50 Eco homes
in 15 million pound project given go
ahead and it seems to indicate to people
that this was a fake accompli when
clearly as we know an aspect has been
discussed this was only the first stage
in a very long process
did slightly
tee up the community to um to strongly
object so the proposals that came
forward at the community engagement
event
clearly we don't have any control of
what the newspapers say but it did cause
a certain amount of consternation in the
community
Parish Council have proposed this
potential land swap within the village
which would provide land for a
low-carbon housing scheme whilst
retaining the current site for future
education provision so if if this
proposal is to come back to cabinet
which I'm glad to hear they're willing
to discuss it again I hope that this
possibility will have been explored and
discussed prior to a decision being made
I'm really pleased to hear that the um
some formal pre-application planning
advice has now been received um and I'd
be very interested in seeing that if
that's possible but
um really grateful that the the call is
not contested and I think it would will
end up with it in a better place with a
better decision if cabinet looks at it
again thank you chair
yeah thank you Council Ballard
um so at this point
um I have to ask for councilor Lawley
councilor Richardson and councilman to
leave
thank you now we have an opportunity to
debate the issue and we have to take one
of
two possible courses of action and
whichever course of action we take we
have to give reasons
why
we either want to refer it back
cabinet door to
um
our uphold the cabinet decision and
implement it immediately
um does anybody have a desire that the
decision should be upheld and
implemented immediately
I think not so
if if that is if that's if it's the case
then that members are minded to refer
them at a back to cabinet for
reconsideration
um
what are our reasons for doing so
I think we've been offered
a couple of reasons
and they were for further public
engagement and to
uh and to look at the planning advice
was it would appear that the planning
advice has been
sought and may have been received but
has not been considered so it's for
further public consultation
consideration of the
planning advice so Council act pretty
young
I think I'm just mindful that given that
councilor Morley is happy to have this
preferred backward cabinet then
presumably she's also happy that
um one of the
points raised in the call-in regarding
the review of alternative sites
throughout the district should also be
considered which I think in itself would
probably be a very useful exercise in
any case
right is there anything else anyone
would like to add
councilor Caston
thank you very much I won't keep you um
too long because it doesn't it seems
like um we've we've got a direction
we're going in now and um it's it's a
very obvious Direction but um
all I all I wanted to say was I can I
can understand the thought process
behind this because we own the site it's
in the HRA account
so it um
it does it does seem like a lot of what
we're trying to do here would is
development control and committee
territory and seeing whether the site's
viable and whether the um you know
whether it's acceptable to build houses
on there I think um
I'm
I hope it I hope this still happens
because it I've been very proud speaking
to the um Parish councils about this
site and the quality and the um the
forward
looking-ness of the way this is designed
I can understand
um residents worries about it but I
would obviously that would go to a
planning meeting and that would all be
heard properly
um it's just um it seems like um
the um this is exactly what we should be
doing in the council this is
um that this is why I've spoken about
this in Parish Council meetings and um
being a um strong supporter of it
because we do need to build to a
standard that we expect and been on a
planning committee I see all the time um
things coming forward to a standard
that's well that's below this but is
acceptable so um
I am I'm not
you know to finish I just wanted to say
it's um I do feel like a lot of what
we're doing here is we're doing work at
the development control and committee
because the council's found a field
and said that could have the Exemplar
housing on it and then that's got to go
to um the development control committee
just like any other business so we're
kind of we're almost
I don't I just don't I don't I don't
massively see the point of it but as
we're in this position and as the leader
of mid-suffolk has said she's quite
happy for it to go back to Cabinet
um we'll um we'll leave it at that and
it will go back to Cabinet but it does
worry me that this could not happen now
and I think this would be such a great
thing for the area and I understand that
residents might disagree Bethany and
there's a petition of them saying that
but this sort of housing is exactly what
we need and
um Council Mellon said the last there's
already been some in 2008 but I'd say we
need ex Exemplar housing everywhere in
mid-suffolk all at every house we build
should be to this standard sadly we're
not going to get this but um I don't
think just because there's been some
before we shouldn't say well that's
that's not changed anything because it I
think it does and the more we can the
the better standard for environmentally
friendliness and efficiency of houses
the better from in in my view but sorry
I I think I think you agree with much of
what councilman said I think that where
he and you would probably differ is
whether it has to be in elsewhere when
else will has already got several
hundred new affordable homes so it built
to a lower standard and I think the
point is if that were the best place in
the whole of the district
to have another Exemplar scheme all well
and good but if it's not the best place
and we don't know where there is unless
unless other sites are considered uh Mr
chairman if I may um what my answer to
that would be this is a HRA land that we
own that we're not going to have to buy
and this this scheme doesn't work if we
buy the land the the figures don't add
up we can't do it we can't possibly do
it so it we might have other options
that's within the HRA account I haven't
I haven't seen them but for this kind of
development this is the perfect place
and we own the land but the development
control committee would decide on that
and um the and councilor Mellon said um
he he support broadly supports the
intentions of the scheme but what is
this cabinet decision if it's not the
intentions of the scheme are supported
let's let the planning committee do the
um the details and work out whether
that's acceptable it's I'm
I understand you know what I'm saying
but I know I know that we we're going
one way with this meeting and I don't
want to and keep everyone here all
afternoon but um I just felt like
talking unpacking what I was thinking
about this in my head and I hope you
don't mind
thank you very much
because open your your hand was up are
you are you in a position to make a
proposal before
we go any further uh not not quite yet
I think the the point I wanted to make
is that
um although there are there have been uh
exemplars homes built in msol previously
they clearly would have been built to a
technology of the time and indeed
technology has moved on massively and I
don't know if anyone's actually looked
at the scheme that's being proposed but
it is basically using the most modern
Technologies and materials to deliver
what will be a outstanding homes for the
community and I think the other point to
point out is that
um this this how this land actually
um if we were to go down the route that
councilor Mellon suggested could then
lie fellow for a large number of years
when we know that housing especially
affordable housing and green housing if
we may use that term is much more
has a much more immediate demand and and
to to confirm uh councilor Carson's uh
Point yeah the the scheme is not going
to get off the ground if we have to buy
the land
right
um
there's probably no oh Council Carter
sorry
well I'd like to say but I completely
agree that we should be setting this as
a standard
as has been argued for I don't know how
many years but we should be holding
example of housing for many years
it's just unfortunate that we seem to
have skipped a step in not doing the
public correct engagement beforehand
wherever the engagement with the ideas
were already in place
and that's a option of a land stop what
which may not possibly may not have been
raised have had gone straight to
planning it may not have been heard or
might be in the right right place but I
certainly agree
fully supportive of we always supported
for the the example of housing
but we do have to be mindful as well of
not just housing now we have to be
mindful of what is necessary in the
future
and if we are looking at putting housing
in place and making it so that people
moving into the area may have to
leave their children on a bus going to
cross the A14 may not have places there
may not actually have a bus a place to
go in place
I would argue that's a bus that comes
twice a day isn't exactly the most ideal
thing rather than it being clearly
transported
but if we have if we get the engagement
right
first and then move on decisions later
ideal but fully supportive that is goes
back to cabinets to have an idea to have
the engagement and get the work of the
footwork in place properly rather than
just saying that we're no throwing baby
without bath water
thank you thank you
is anybody in a position to make a
proposal
please
I would propose that we don't refer this
back to cabinet
we don't refer it back correct
do we have a second though
right
we will lead
are you happy I'm
are you content that we now we now take
a vote on that without any further
debate
we will take a vote that it is not
referred back to cabinet
we have to take the vote don't we look
at the yes
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
see if it works this time
thank you chair that is free votes for
and free against
do we have a counter proposal
cancer scarf
well bearing in mind that the government
prepared to take another look at it I
can't see why we can't refer the matter
back to cabinet for reconsideration I
think we've had some valid reasons given
University
Illustrated to us so they can form our
observations and then cabinet can take a
final decision but I'd just like to
query if the matter goes back to cabinet
and then cabinet makes a decision is
that then exempt from a call in in
future if members feel that the cabinet
still made the wrong decision
at a later date of cabinet just a
technical query because I would like
that like to know what that would be but
I'm quite happy to make the recommend
yes Joe that's quite correct if it goes
if it's a referral back to to Cabinet
from this committee then it's exempt
from calling when the final decision is
made
if they debate it and they come up with
something different but quite similar
then that is not exempt from connect if
it's a different decision yeah yes thank
you
so
um we need
we need grounds for we need reasons so
the reasons that councilor Morley gave
were
that they would take it back for further
public engagement
and consideration of
planning advice
before
a further decision by cabinet and one of
one of uh one of you said and
consideration of other sites within the
district so would you wish that to be
added I'm very happy for that to chair
because I think unless you consider
other sites in the district you don't
know the answer May well be there are no
other sites but I think considerations
should be taken by the cabinet
okay
so that then reads something along the
lines of
we refer them out about the cabinet for
reconsideration with the following
observations of the overview of scrutiny
committee
that officers take uh
hold further public engagement and
a cabinet considered and consideration
of other sites within the district
and consideration of a big consideration
of playing advice before the decision
taken by cabinet something along those
lines
do I do I have a second though
you
Wonder
I I I think I don't think that's
necessary to put it in there
in there
um if they're going to
consider other sites they have to
in my view it would have to be a wide
consideration and there has been that
offer has been made so I can't consider
it they can't consider other sites
without considering the site it's been
offered to them
in my view
so can we put that you can tend to put
that to the vote
so are you
I'm sorry yes
you're happy to take it thank you
thank you chair that is four votes for
one against one abstention so it's
carried
I believe that now is the end of the
meeting
if I look at my script
um thank you very much yes so that
concludes the business of the VT and it
is 3 15.